here's how to sync a Google calendar to
your tungle
account first click calendars and
contacts on the left click add new
calendar and contact sync source and
select Google from the
list type in the email address of the
account you want to
sync and here you can choose if you also
want to import your Google contacts
which is Handy if you want to access
your contacts when scheduling
meetings click
continue
and we're brought over to a Google site
asking us to Grant access click Grant
access and we go back to
tungle if you have other Google
Calendars shared with your main account
that you've just synced tongle will give
you the option to connect those as well
select the ones you want to
connect and click
continue and you're
done you'll now see the events from your
Google calendar in your
account